I'm Joe Dunkley and I'm here to tell you
about three amazing women astronomers
who in the late 19th and 20th centuries
faced down challenges many of us would
recognize today despite the obstacles
they each managed to change the way we
understand the universe astronomer
Henrietta Swan Leavitt joined Harvard
College Observatory in 1895 she was part
of an extraordinary group of women known
as the Harvard computers their job was
to classify stars using photographic
images as women they weren't allowed to
operate the telescope's themselves and
were paid very little Leavitt studied
stars that get brighter and dimmer over
time she discovered a pattern in 1908
now known as Levitz law which says that
a star that takes longer to pulse is
intrinsically brighter than a star that
pulses quickly this means that just by
measuring the rate of pulsing which
might be days or weeks and by seeing how
bright the star appears from earth an
astronomer can find out how far away it
is this was transformational Edwin
Hubble used Levitz discovery in the
1920s to work out that smudges of light
in the sky were in fact entire galaxies
far beyond our own the universe was much
bigger than we thought I have such
admiration for Leavitt because she was
assigned very mundane tasks in her job
yet still made this vital breakthrough
[Music]
Cecilia Payne Capuchin also worked at a
Harvard College Observatory after Swan
Leavitt in the early 1920s she used the
latest learnings about quantum physics
to come up with the idea that stars are
all made mainly of hydrogen and
helium gas up until then no one had
known what stars are made of they were
thought to have similar ingredients to
our planet earth pain kibosh concedes
that stars are much simpler than anyone
thought
however the well-known astronomer Henry
Norris Russell advised her to remove her
idea from her PhD thesis in 1925 as it
went against the current wisdom just a
few years later payne gap Ashkan will be
proved right she would later go on to
become the first female head of
astronomy at Harvard University
I wonder if panca poskim would have been
discouraged from her bold new idea if
she had been a man luckily it didn't
stop her from achieving great things
Vera Rubin was an American astronomer
she finished her studies in the 1950s
while juggling caring for her young
children often having to attend lectures
in the evenings Rubin wants to study how
entire galaxies spin and she became the
first woman allowed to use the Palomar
Observatory in California at the time
there was no women's bathroom but
undeterred Rubin pasted a paper skirt on
the men's bathroom door to create her
own Rubin discovered something
surprising all of the galaxies she
looked at was spinning too fast as if
something more massive but completely
invisible was holding them together
Rubin showed that every galaxy is
surrounded by huge halo of invisible
dark matter 50 years later we still
don't know what it is
Rubin story inspires me her discovery is
so important to my current research and
I relate to her as a mother trying to
balance doing science with looking after
young children
it's no
easy but it's a fun challenge these
women all made great discoveries in
astronomy and despite being little-known
throughout their lives their stories
continue to inspire women across the
world if you enjoyed this video
subscribe to the BBC ideas YouTube
channel for more
[Music]